hello how are you doing okay
no i don't want to do that sorry no
problem at all
you're scaring me hey i got the right
property i think you're with evans my
friend
evans hi hello uh i'm evan's business
partner would we be able to show
our friend this apartment
he scares you why does he scare you
he's very professional my tenant is
english yeah
10 years yeah very very good english
gentleman
very good our only trust in english
you only trust english people but you're
not english yourself yeah i only tried
my
my partner is english i only trust
english people
my wife is african i'm not trust but if
you don't trust anyone who isn't english
the business owner is evans and evans is
from the caribbean
so if that's gonna mean that you can't
do business with him
then we can't do business because evans
is the company director
probably have to call it a day
she's so
she said that she won't do business
with us because you're the company
director and you're
not english these are kind of things
like go through you know sometimes i'm
glad that you were there to witness it
i believe that you're interested in a
couple of our rental properties and you
guys are
subletters right uh yeah and then what
sort of um
clientele are you be getting into
property what sort of profile of
applicant do you sort of usually
so it's gonna be you know young
professionals they are well vetted and
stuff
all right evans what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna send you over a couple of
properties across that are in healing i
am in the healing area so if i do like
it i'll get back to you shoppish
perfect all right thank you muffy speak
to you soon
great to meet you guys thanks for
letting us come around
the property actually looks it looks all
right the location is obviously good
yeah now my thing is is the landlord is
he um
is he open to doing uh guaranteed rent
um
what guarantees renting it to a company
is it open to you
to the concept could be it could be as
long as your man there is a guarantor
why not because this was used as a
renter and before wasn't it yeah it was
okay cool they're not doing anything
i mean look at me i mean do i look like
anybody with anything illegal
you are okay with having a guaranteed
rent for on a corporate alert as long as
you
know that the money's going to come in
yes that's right yeah that's exactly
what they want
okay so should we shall we make a deal
why don't we just work out what the
funnel off we could put forward is then
um and then and then let me just have to
be right it's regardless
yeah shall we show them 76 or it's up to
that i mean
do you want to see the other one yeah
yeah that'd be great yeah just do it
yeah okay
thanks 700 times five why can't we just
send our final offer at the end of the
day even go around now
if they're in hello all right are you
okay
uh it's uh thank you yeah um in regards
to the property
yeah um is it possible i can go view it
now
oh yeah are you there now uh i'm
literally here now yeah
you're there now yes correct okay i'm
coming i'll see you soon
okay yeah um well basically it'll be a
company left
okay so yeah listen space
cool so this is the first double room
and it's got
three rooms upstairs and then two
reception rooms downstairs
i really like this one samuel it's got
two bathrooms
um it's called you know it's very tidy
very clean
modern and for where it is
it's quite cheap they've advertised it
themselves
yeah who's interested in having the
property it's it it'll be our company
it'll be we wouldn't be happy
well that's um i mean what's it on for
116.
why eighteen hundred eighteen hundred
yeah ideally what is it that you really
want
well yeah it would be good to give to a
company okay yeah it would be good
because then you get you know it's
guaranteed isn't it yeah yeah
yeah than people just moving out after a
few months if we guaranteed the rent
for say three years of a three month
break loss yeah
what would be the lowest you'd be able
to accept and still live with if we
could guarantee the rent
so no late payments no management costs
that much 1800 1800 is what it's on for
obviously you you wouldn't have to
manage it we would take care of
all that so you just get a
straightforward uh monthly rent okay you
didn't talk to mr singh
yeah okay yeah his number yeah yeah we
have yeah yeah
we're going to record in a bit then
shall we just work out the fine details
but thank you ever so much for coming
over here let us know
around great thank you so much and have
you got any other properties or is that
the only one that you've got
has a seven bedroom in um west ealing
is that available at the moment yeah you
want to see it yeah that'd be great
yes but we'll follow you down thank you
thanks jess
i think that one's gonna work always ask
the question what else have you got
i liked that i liked that well done i
think that's gonna work that
so four beds we'd rent each room out for
about 700
smaller one a bit less they want
eighteen hundred but oh i'm very
confident we're gonna get
yeah hundred percent we just need two
thousand pounds a month in rental rents
two thousand pounds a month in deal
packaging that's your four grand that's
enough
for you to be able to rent your london
apartment
that's what i'm thinking this is my
lunch and breakfast
yes combined just a carpet
how we basically make our money so with
this for instance this property
if we were to pay you a monthly rent we
would pay
the landlord a guaranteed rent and then
we then
manage it take on all the hassle and
responsibility and then we make a fee
you know obviously we make up um a
margin on it
yeah well we'll calculate it but of
course we need to make money on it
yeah um so we'll work out what we'd get
if it was completely full
yeah and then we'll put 10 down four
voids yeah
10 down for maintenance 10 have a profit
yeah
and then we'll then offer a guaranteed
event based on that basis so we'll be
getting
a monthly a small monthly profit yeah
we'll have to factor in costs
and hopefully we'll better take the
pressure off a little bit of the of the
tenant stuff
but real pleasure i hope we can do
business if the numbers can work
um as long as we're getting you know
profit from it
um and then from your perspective you
don't want the hassle so
we'll see if we can work out thank you
so much thank you see you soon
cheers bye we're gonna get a deal with
them 100
i'm really really excited it's recently
been refurbished it's an eight bedroom
already licensed for 15 people
how far is it how far away are we from
your house
about 10 minutes oh nice see that's the
thing there are deals
on your doorstep
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not open to it that's no
problem at all just keep my number if
anything changes
nothing's going to change okay that's
fine for your call anyway i appreciate
it cheers bye stop him you know what's
happening though when you become like
more like i don't care
yeah it's a company that no there's not
a guarantor
but you know what here's what i can
offer you bang bang bang with confidence
because
you don't give a monkeys you why because
you're prepared to walk away
oh you don't accept company let's now
we're like we got too many company let's
take a hike bum we're good we're good
fool
like we got loads we got too many houses
to view
we i i can't even cope with how many
estate agents and latin agents and
landlords are saying we want a company
that we want a company left 100 so
generally speaking do you think it's
better to email or to call
i think i think both in fact i think
everything i think you need to email i
think you need to phone
i think you just walk in to the shop i
think you need to go to viewings where
you haven't booked the viewing just not
the freaking door
i think what we're doing now is
everything everything
it's like when you go to war you don't
just go with one weapon you go with your
whole weapon right
so we need to go with everything which
is what we are doing which is why we're
gonna get deal right now
and what what why does this something
say 20 minutes this one says 23 minutes
why do we even have two stat naps we're
using this one just turn this around
you might imagine what would happen if i
work as hard as this
every day you should man it's the
seventh feeling of the day do you know
the crazy thing is actually before i
used to work hard until today
are you coming or not yes um actually
what it is
we've obviously been stuck in in um in a
viewing um
also just be careful of using the word
obviously too much yeah
especially when it's not obvious what we
found is that letting agents find it
really difficult to rent out three bed
flats
because most people want a one bed or
maybe a two bed but if we can turn the
three bed flat and we can change one of
the reception rooms into our bedroom by
putting a bed in it
and we can take into a four bed flat we
can then rent the rooms out room room
room room
and turn it into a multi-let so as long
as we can get permission from the
landlord
as long as we can get permission from
the head lease if it's a leasehold
property
we can make really good monthly cash
flow by renting it for a cheap rent
because no one wants it
turning it into a multi-let and keeping
the profit in between
to be honest we're finding the three
beds are really hard to really
our company we've got we have an
overpopulation of people wanting to rent
out our yeah
our properties would would the landlord
looking for like a long-term
yeah we've got bright claws in there
he's okay with that
cool and what do you think would there
be any
objections if we if we had um people
if we had people in the rooms like a
multi-let would that be
do you know if there's any restrictions
on the lease or anything to stop that
happening i don't think so no
i spoke to my manager about it this
morning should be okay okay cool
i think this i think this one could work
it's a good really good location
so what i really like about three
bedroom flats is that you can turn the
fourth
living room reception room to a fourth
bed and the best thing about it is that
you don't need an hmo license
because if we can if we can rent these
for like 1750 a month
well then we can rent out the rooms for
750 each 750 550 that's 3 000 pounds
that leaves us with over a thousand
pounds we're going to pay the bills
we've got a little bit of bits and bobs
we should be able to easily make a
minimum of 500 pounds profit
maybe even 700 pounds profit oh it looks
really nice though this this does yeah
entirely it's good i do prefer this one
even i liked the last one but this one
which one are you more motivated to let
either anything at this time
with this one would it be the same story
with the landlord he'd be happy
for us to rent it out on multi as a
monster there and a corporate letter
okay cool
oh i like it